[Music]  some heroes are unshakable others are  unstoppable but only one Kai is part of  a portable 10 piece set  Rex dasha at your service  [Music]  prax - for your next mission we're  partnering you with two civilians Dale  and well play this one after me this was  just garbage over the last several  months a top secret organization has  caused citizens from different lands to  vanish into thin air  that's not good I need you two to help  rescue them we're running out of time  I'm 100% almost sure  this entire city is guarded day time to  go save the world  [Applause]  that was terrifying but also kind of  exhilarating  Rex I know you love me you don't need to  say  um I was just gonna say you forgot your  sunglasses tell the boss tells here to  see her I got a Dell down here asking to  see Miss G no not Adele that'd be  awesome  [Music]